Russell Crowe what was the thing with
Michael Jackson this is such an odd
story what oh he just got into the habit
of wherever I was staying he'd just call
the hotel and asked my room and put on
funny voices I didn't I've never met him
you know the first couple of people that
I said it to I was like I didn't want to
sound like I was insane right Michael
you know prank called me today when I
actually started talking people who
really knew him well they got manic
decimal time but it was like yeah it was
like a thing I used to do that when I
was like 11 and 12 I used to pretend I
was a radio announcer and like give
people prizes I would get so excited
just hang up and go out that was a good
job well done I made that pretend to be
Oh always start off being kind of gruff
like he was the hotel management and
there was some kind of problem
surprisingly saying you're Michael
Jackson then if I got kind of irritating
you go
[Applause]
you ever meet him he are we sure it was
Michael Jackson II sure was in George
Clooney cuz that's the kind of thing he
does is it it could have been George no
it was Martin
I remember they are you loser this is
such a low point you [__] loser you
know like that and then I will his belly
went in my mouth